i joined salomon brothers in 1990 this
is the time when John good friend was
still there this is the time that the
book liars poker came out I worked on a
fixed income trading floor the word big
swinging dick was established at that
point I worked in the most machismo
masculine straight difficult environment
so bad there were many times I wanted to
quit because of the discriminatory
behavior the comments the notes left on
my desk fortunately at one point I came
out to my boss and it turns out he was
extremely extremely homo friendly and he
was quite shocked that I was
experiencing such a difficult time on
the trading floor at Salomon Brothers
and what he did is he had a meeting with
the entire trading for one day when I
went home and told people that in his
environment on this trading floor there
was going to be no discrimination there
was going to be no making anybody
uncomfortable and Solomon was a very
diverse culture there were many
minorities of every type working on the
trading floor there were many women and
for that many of those some gay people
as well and I was the first person that
I that I know of it actually came out on
the Solomon trading for and I was known
as a gay guy a gay professional I was
also a top salesman and I think people
respected that I was so successful and
coming out ended up being being a good
experience in me at solomon and i was
comfortable being out and forward about
it and i think my clients and my clients
for that matter many of them knew I were
gay and it worked fine and I would even
get invitations to parties both
corporate as well as personal parties
where my significant other was invited
my partner was invited to corporate
corporate outings and I was proud to be
a leader in the gay community of being
out and successful after I came out to
my boss and I think he and some not so
indirect after I came out to my boss and
in a very direct fashion he made it
clear to everybody on the Solomon
trading floor that making somebody
that's gay uncomfortable would be
totally unacceptable it became it it
became much easier to work there I think
people generally speaking are not
homophobes they they just go with the
stereotypes but once they realize that
one is among them it all falls in place
I think the same thing in the army
everybody thinks that you know gays in
the military organico
unit the opposite of cohesion they're
going to disrupt unit unit behavior but
it turns out most people don't have an
issue with it but everybody thinks
somebody else has an issue with it so
people don't have an issue generally
speaking with gay and we're in a very
little city New York anyhow
any troubles starting with copy being
gay entrepreneur in the real estate
development is being gay has been a bit
of a challenge most of the people in the
construction industry are pretty pretty
straight pretty tough and I think that
they might view gay men developing real
estate man as a client as easier and
we've had to be very firm working with
our construction crews and to make it
clear that we're as tough and as nimble
as any straight or gay businessman
favorite gay icon and why um just shows
I don't think about people gear straight
just think about people who are talented
my favorite geek okay good my favorite
gay icon by ship I my favorite gay icon
would be the head of the City Council in
New York christine quinn number 22 the
mayor talented smart open out vocal that
is a great icon she's a real leader in
the community in the gay community and
she's a real spiritual leader in the
city and she's a real leader of the city
so Christine Quinn would be my favorite
gay icon